jennifer lopez and ben affleck have said
i do
and jennifer shares the proof to her
newsletter on the jlo
like these photos of the ceremony in las
vegas
and videos of the couple getting ready
before walking down the aisle
how are you feeling
i feel
so excited you look gorgeous
somebody's getting married
and this
was my
wedding
changing area
meanwhile a source tells et quote ben is
absolutely in love with jyn and feels
loved by her too
we're also learning ben and jen quote
feel like they are in the same place in
life now and relate to each other on
another level you know it's wild to
think about it that way as the couple
looks to the future the source says
quote they're so excited to make more
memories together and have more
adventures both as a couple and as a
family
[Applause]
it's a full circle moment for these two
who rekindled their romance in 2021
after months of speculation jennifer and
ben became instagram official with a
pick of them locking lips on vacay
and this second chance that love follows
the never ending spotlight on their
romance in the early 2000s can you see
if we can get in the papers
ben and jen began dating in 2002 quickly
followed by the couple announcing their
engagement but in 2003 the wedding was
called off just days before their
planned ceremony in september and they
officially called off the engagement in
january 2004 but remained on friendly
terms following the split it was my
first kind of heartbreak lopez opened up
about their breakup to et in 2014. we
were about to get married
it didn't work out and it was just a bad
heartbreak like you know just one of
those breakups that really it was like a
tough one for me fast forward to 2022
jayla revealed in april that ben popped
the question it was totally unexpected
what else was unexpected
the full breakdown jlo gave her fans of
the moment been proposed ben came in and
he got down on one knee
and he said some things that i'll never
forget
and then he pulled out a ring
and he said will you marry me
and it was
the most perfect moment
and he hands me a ring
ben even makes an off-screen cameo at
the end
feeling so lucky it's not often you get
a
second chance at true love
we feel very lucky
i love you
[Music]